- I know that he masturbates a lot.
That's kind of weird.
(upbeat electric guitar)
- I did a Heisenberg thing.
- Ohhhh.
- But also a super nice dude. (laughing)
- I don't think, I don't
strike you as an emoji guy.
- I used some emojis.
- Oh, I'm disappointed.
With a, with a MOM tattoo.
- I used these ones a lot.
If you're really close with
me, I'll give you a turtle.
- One is rated PG, and one is rated R.
- Jackass, Motherfucker.
I wrote Fiddlesticks. (laughing)
- (Laughs) Pretty close.
- Just add masturbating to that.
- (Scribbling) You got a short answer.
- Two words.
- Slow down?
Do some meaningful pointed work.
(laughing)
- Nice.
- I think we can start dating.
I think it's, you know,
I think we know enough
about each other now.
(making ESP sounds)
- I feel like I should know this.